[Music]
Grindle Bart's been in jail in New York
for a few months the decision is made to
move him back to Europe where he has to
answer for the crimes that he is
committed and inevitably he escaped
credence survives and for Chris the big
question now is I want to know who I am
the path has been laid he is following
it the trails that we didn't to me the
reason everyone goes to Paris really is
Creedence we may not know who he is here
but he needs to be found and I rather
hope you might be the one to find
Dumbledore has to maneuver to try and
stop little volts rise then why there is
a new threat as Grindelwald mobilizes
he's a master manipulator and that is
why he is so dangerous we're heading
toward war everyone's choosing sides
things are becoming much more dark and
complicated and people's and agencies
are now being exposed
you must rise up we take our rightful
place in the world we're now getting
into the meat of the story and
everything gets darker and more
intricate whatever you think you know at
the end of the movie might not be the
case
[Music]
it's a dress I'm saying a safe house in
Paris why would I need a safe house
embarrassed rude things at some point go
terribly wrong it's good to have a place
to go you know for a cup of tea five
brothers my sisters the clock is ticking
fast
my dream we who live forces before last
moment has come to take our rightful
place
where we was it's free
join me
we'll die
The Wizarding of Nan visiting worlds
have been at peace for over a century
in the world wants to see that piece
destroyed
you want me to hunt him down to kill him
[Music]
then would I why can't you go I cannot
let the guys Grindle's off
it has to be here
you don't suffer from motion sickness
see I don't do well on boats you'll be
fine
you know why I admire eunuch
we do not seek power you simply ask is
the thing right
[Music]
the times coming
when you have to pick a side I don't do
sides
[Music]
okay something
buuuut you never met a monster you
couldn't love let's take
that's your brother I think that might
have been the best moment of my life
[Music]